la france à l'aube du stade iii de
l'épidémie de corona virus tandis que le
pays se prépare face à la hausse des
contaminations edouard philippe a
annoncé ce vendredi des mesures
concernant l'oise et le haut rhin les
deux départements français les plus
touchés
nous annonçons ce soir un renforcement
des mesures qui limitent les contacts la
fermeture à compter de lundi matin et
pour 15 jours des crèches maternelles
collèges et lycées dans les autres
départements
l'ensemble des mesures déjà en vigueur
reste inchangé le haut rhin qui fait
face à une hausse spectaculaire avec la
multiplication par huit du nombre de
personnes contaminées par le virus en
seulement 48 heures un député l ère du
haut-rhin jean-luc right there a
notamment été hospitalisés en
réanimation
en visite dans une maison de retraite à
paris emmanuel macron en a profité pour
préciser certaines priorités notamment
celle qui consiste à protéger les
personnes les plus fragiles
nous sommes vous le savez encore dans ce
qu'on appelle cette phase 2 en train
d'essayer de ralentir l'épidémie de
covile 19
nous passerons dans sans doute les
prochains jours dans une nouvelle phase
quand l'ensemble des régions est que le
virus sera plus largement répandus où il
faudra continuer de lutter contre ce
virus en protégeant les personnes qui
sont les plus fragiles et c'est
aujourd'hui cela notre priorité
le ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
a d'ailleurs annoncé le déclenchement du
plan blanc dans tous les hôpitaux
nous venons de décider pour l'ensemble
du territoire la mise sous sortent sous
tension de l'ensemble des établissements
de santé et médico-sociaux qui dope qui
déclencheront leur plan de mobilisation
interne qui correspond au démarrage de
leur plan blanc pour les hôpitaux et
pour les cliniques et le plan bleu pour
les ehpad et les autres mais
établissements médico sociaux
nous avons augmenté le nombre
d'établissements de santé de première et
de seconde ligne
ils sont désormais 150 sur tout le
territoire national
et je rappelle que dans chaque
département il ya au moins un
établissement de santé
capable d'accueillir des patients de a à
z des mesures drastiques qui laisse
entrevoir celle attendue à l'échelle
nationale toutes les régions de france
métropolitaine sont désormais touchés
par le coronavirus
[Musique]